trevor is with us in Oklahoma City hi
Trevor how are you I'm doing great how
are you sir
better than I deserve what's up well I
wanted to call real quick I currently
work for an oil and gas company working
in Aichi uh do pretty well but I'm kind
of realizing uh it between all the
people we support it's my director and
me and I'm kind of realizing that oh I'm
this is probably where I'm going to be
for a while there's no moving up from
here and the IT world as far as this
company goes I treat is great and it's a
great place to be but I'm trying to
figure out if this is exactly what I
want to do for rest of my life I'm
working on five projects here and there
creatively so it I'm trying to figure
out if I can take off with those at some
point but this does consume a lot of my
time
plus I have a wife and a child so it's
one of those things where time is
limited and I'm just trying to find out
how should I go about trying to find out
what I want to do for the rest of my
life well I think rightly what you're
doing is what you want to do the rest of
your life
maybe the position you're in you like
you like the IT aspect of your life it's
just that you feel like you've capped
out there because it's not a growing IT
department that's going to allow you the
opportunity to move up right right
correct you know so I mean if you just
had IT where you had that solved in an
environment where you're treated well
then you'd be okay wouldn't you yeah
definitely but a big part of it too is
I'm actually pretty creative person I
kind of stumbled into ie and it's just
kind of taken off for me as the years
gone on but I have these creative
endeavors that I'm always like on time
for it later and I never really push on
them just because or gets in the way or
you know but the good thing is about my
work though that they're very aware of
my uh other side products that I do when
they're kind of supportive about it too
so um well I mean you do have time it's
just a matter of when I mean for
instance turn off the television and
spend that time with family and then
when the kids go to bed you've got time
at night my first book was written
between 10:00 p.m. and 2:00 a.m. yeah
yeah but nobody bothered with me during
nobody wanted me or needed me between
10:00 p.m. and 2:00 a.m. I have another
friend of mine that gets up at 5:00 a.m.
and he works on side projects for an
hour hour and a half to 6:30 and then he
gets ready and goes to work yeah you can
get up at 5:00 a.m. but the only problem
with that is you got to go bad you can't
respond oh yeah you can't stay up to him
you know you're not gonna know what
Conan said or whoever's on at night
right right you're right you're right
whoever those guys are Jimmy Kimmel
that's who's I don't even know because I
go to bed I get up at 5:00 you know yeah
I'm not mad at those guys I just don't
watch that that stuff because I'm in bed
so and I just I changed my habits years
ago because my morning time is really
really productive for me for prayer for
brainstorming I jump on Twitter I jump
on to answer a bunch of my emails I'll
read through manuscript stuff I have to
review and I can get a lot of work done
during that hour and a half in the
morning before I start getting ready and
come to the office so you know you just
kind of got to find your time like that
and say okay I'm going to budget this
particular piece of time to work on some
things that I think might open up some
passions in me and if they did then you
can move that towards either a career
change with someone in that field the
creative field or you can move it
towards a small business idea where you
launch your own idea but then you've got
a budget even more time to get that
launch so but to at least font to answer
your question how do I find what I want
to do well what you'll do is you'll find
some things you don't want to do by
working on those projects at night or in
the morning and then you'll find some
things they that was fun and that type
of person and that type of project I
like that and then take on some more of
those and then see if that doesn't it
doesn't start to grow for you and take
your time on that there's a great book
out that discusses these kinds of things
we published it here called start and
it'll help you with a lot of those kinds
of ideas particularly philosophically so
hold on and I'll have Kelly pick up I'll
send you a free copy of the book start
you